bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler de
smartphones alors c'est souvent
difficile de choisir le bon smartphone
parce que quand on a un petit budget
quand on veut mettre moins de 400 euros
sera un smartphone savoir faire un peu
la différence dans tous ses produits
d'entrée de gamme c'est difficile
pourtant il ya quelques différences sont
notables j'ai sélectionné en tout sept
produits différents le au nord 9 wayuu
et nova 2 iphone est ce samedi xperia x1
ultra samsung galaxy à 5 motorola moto x
4 et le wiko view prime d'ailleurs vos
amis des liens du tout c'est prudent
description bien vous pouvez aller les
voir alors bien évidemment on va
regarder la fiche technique on va
regarder le prix de ses produits on va
regarder les spécifications on va
regarder les points forts et les points
faibles est-ce qu'il va le cours à
qu'ils destinent et puis à la fin je
vous dirai quel est mon peau nue et
lequel moi si je vais faire ce choix si
je devais choisir un smartphone à moins
de 400 euros lequel je prendrais on y va
[Musique]
je vous rassure j'ai fait un choix un
peu arbitraire il ya d'autres marques
proposent des produits d'entrée de gamme
à moins de 400 euros mais c'était
compliqué de comparer 10 15 modèles l'a
déjà j'en ai pris s'être fait quand même
beaucoup beaucoup donc on va se
concentrer sur ces produits là on
commence par le au nord 9 un écran 5
points 15 pouces c'est un écran lcd en
full hd c'est à dire 1920 par 1080 c'est
assez standard à l'arrière on va
retrouver deux caméras côté photo il est
le seul à avoir un 20 mégapixels
monochrome et 1 12 mégapixels en
couleurs l'objectif ouvre en 2.2 sur la
fage vous avez ici la caméra avant pour
la selle fillon n'est une caméra en 8
mégapixels et on peut faire de la vidéo
en 4k pour l'avoir testé le au nord 9
pour la photo est bien est correct de
toute façon tous les freenautes on parle
sont des produits à moins de 400 euros
donc il faut pas chercher des trucs avec
des performances de dingue mais en tout
cas le au no 9 a vraiment une qualité
qui complètement convenable un
processeur kirin 960 4 gigas de ram on
n'est pas sur les tous derniers version
des processeurs pour trouver sur le web
par contre quelque chose qui tourne bien
et 64 giga de stockage qu'on peut monter
jusqu'à 256 giguère côté design il est
élégant alors déjà en termes de prise en
main c'est un bruit qui est plutôt
agréable qui se tient bien dans la main
on va vraiment une finition très premium
très clairement de se produire vous
voyez
l'aspect vers un aspect très brillant on
a une coque arrière qui est incurvé avec
un aspect 3d ça renforce vraiment ce que
tu es premium de ce produit
l'inconvénient sur les traces de doigts
je ne sais pas si ça se voit gala et
vous avez plein de traces de doigts il
faut forcément toujours un petit peu de
nettoyer si on veut garder le côté un
peu brillant du smartphone côté batterie
on a une 3200 milliampères heures donc
normalement pas de surprise on reste
dans les moyennes de ce qui se fait
actuellement sur les smartphones j'ai
fait un petit tour du stand exportations
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
tourne plutôt bien il tourne sous
android 7.0 nigga avec une surcouche
emotion 85.1 il a du bluetooth 4.2 une
prise jack c'est vraiment un produit
globalement est intéressant qui
normalement est vendu à plus de 400
euros mais qu'on peut trouver à moins de
400 euros j'ai vu une offre à 399 euros
je vous mets le lien à la description
point positif de ce produit c'est le
design on n'en réussit toujours ses
produits celui là est vraiment super
jolie le dos en verre et premium
parcours tout le temps passé un petit
coup de chiffon del po qui brille parce
que sinon les traces de doigts c'est pas
génial et ça c'est vraiment le point
négatif ce sont les fameuses strasbourg
alors à qui s'adresse ce produit au nord
c'est une filiale de wide web aux doors
s'adresse à un public jeune 15 25 ans
bon ben ça déborde les jambes au dessus
peuvent les prendre les gens qui sont un
peu plus âgés de 25 ans peuvent les
prendre et en dessous de 15 sa cible
également les gens qui aiment jouer en
termes de performances ça fonctionne si
vous aimez les jeux vous voulez jouer le
honneur 9 marche très bien donc pas de
souci là-dessus donc c'est vrai que voir
ses smartphones qui s'adressent plutôt
un public jeune et aux gamers maintenant
le huawei nova 2 vous avez un écran 5
pouces fhd en 1920 par 1080 l'écran est
un peu plus petit que celui des odeurs 9
niveaux la caméra arrière vous avez une
12 mégapixels et une 8 mégapixels avec
une ouverture en points 8 une caméra
celle fille en 20 mégapixels dès que
l'ouverture 2.4 et pour la vidéo et
films en full hd à 30 images par seconde
côté processeur certains kirin 659 vous
avez 4 gigabits de ram et 64 giga de
stockage interne qui peut monter jusqu'à
250 gigas avec une carte sd côté design
il est assez classique un design
standard rien d'exceptionnel c'était
patrice est une de 1950 milliampères
heures et comme le au nord il a un
androïde 7.0 nougat avec une surcouche
et motion lui cinq points forcément
c'est la même boîte honoré brio et on a
le même environnement du bluetooth 4.2
un port jack et c'est un produit qu'on
trouve à 399 euros quels sont les
avantages de ce produit alors pour moi
ce qui est bien sûr ce produit c'est la
faute aux jeux déjà exporté beaucoup
d'enfants alors l'euro je sais pas si ça
vous pas si vous n'êtes pas forcément en
amateur photo mais l'euro c'est la haute
définition et c'est là où on va garder
je dirais toutes les informations de
votre photo c'est extrêmement pratique
parce que vous travaillez sur photoshop
et vous voulez vraiment travailler dans
la meilleure qualité vous pouvez aussi
faire des photos 3d pour faire une photo
en 3d vous allez prendre votre appareil
vous allez viens pas certains objets et
lui il va le modéliser comme dans matrix
par exemple pouvoir reconnaître les
différentes cours les différentes formes
et ensuite vous les déplacez directement
sur votre téléphone et ça c'est vraiment
très pratique et très sympathique points
négatifs vous filmer uniquement en full
hd à 30 images par seconde donc c'est un
produit qui est plus destiné aux
amateurs de photos maintenant à l'iphone
et seul l'iphone est ce un petit écran
de 4 pouces on a une résolution de 1136
par 640 pixels donc on n'est même pas
sur du full hd un écran lcd de caméras
une à l'arrière de 12 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de 2.2 et l avant 1,2
mégapixels avec une ouverture de 2.4 que
vous pouvez filmer en 4k à 30 images
seconde il ya une puce à 9 2 gigas de
ram et 32 gigas ou 128 go de stockage
bon le design c'est un classique d'apple
un une batterie 1624 millan père heures
il peut tourner sous ios 11 on a du
bluetooth 4 points une prise jack et
c'est un produit peut trouver à 339
euros point positif de ce produit je
dirais c'est la marque hello est ce si
vous aimez l os d'apple si vous êtes
déjà client si vous êtes toutes vos
applications très clairement ça fait le
job c'est très bien point négatif
l'écran vous avez un écran qui n'est
même pas en full hd un écran 4 pouces
avec une résolution qui est un peu
bâtarde et puis vous avez deux gigas de
ram donc vous attendez pas avec une bête
de course vous en ai pas avoir un écran
qui est hyper sympa pouvoir profiter de
belles qualités de vidéos en full hd
c'est un petit produit apple compact
ensuite on arrive sur le sony xperia x1
ultra fait un écran 6 pouces bord à bord
1920 par 1080 lcd l'appareil photo à
l'avant c'est un 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture en 2.0 et un stabilisateur
cliquer dessus l'appareil photo à
l'arrière c'est un 23 mégapixels avec un
autofocus hybride sa roue l'équivalent
de 24 mm avec une ouverture de 2.0 pour
faire des photos en faible luminosité on
peut monter jusqu en iso 6400 ou des
vidéos vous filmer en full hd
normalement c'est pas mal ça fan auto
focus pour l'avant à faire exactement le
même exercice côté processeur on est sur
un processeur médiathèque et llopez 20
64 bits 4 gigas de ram et est dispo en
32 ans 64 giga on peut monter jusqu'à
256 giga lorsque vous effectivement une
carte micro sd ici sur le côté côté
design il a l'aspect industriel qui est
vraiment très très proche c'est un
appareil qui vraiment super esthétique
la prise en main est simple un bord en
aluminium il tourne dos rigides sous
android 7.0 louga la batterie cdu 2700
milliampères peur et le bluetooth séduit
4 points 2 une prise jack et on le
trouve au tarif de 399 euros point
positif la photo en plein jour ça marche
bien pas de souci point négatif une
batterie deux mille sept cent millions
terreur pour un écran de 6 pouces et
sera plus de conseils non à l'autre si
vous mettez la luminosité à fond si vous
jouez seul utiliser énormément votre
écran j'ai peur qu'un moment la batterie
soit un peu moyenne et que vous puissiez
profiter un peu moins d'une journée ce
smartphone se destine vraiment aux
amateurs de sony à ceux qui aiment ce
design sony très particulier maintenant
samsung galaxy à 5 un écran 5 pouces
full hd 1920 par 1080 super amoled une
caméra arrière 16 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture en 1.9 et la même chose pour
la caméra bon côté vidéo c'est du full
hd qu'il tourne tourne à irène cortex à
53 3 giga de ram et 32 gigas de stockage
qui pourrait monter jusqu'à 250 gigas le
design c'est un classique samsung je
dirais une batterie 3000 milliampères
heures et tourne tout un androïde 6.0
marshmallow il a du bluetooth 4 points
une prise jack et on le trouve au tarif
de 319 euros point positif de ce produit
l'écran super amoled
le capteur photo 16 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture 1.9 toute façon samsung pour
les photos ça fait le job en règle
générale c'est samsung les appareils
font vraiment la faire sont sympas dans
les belles photos et là en plus sur un
écran super amoled ça finira sublimer
vos clichés points faibles android 6 po
0 marche cologer sont expliqués à qui
s'adresse ce smartphone tout simplement
à ceux qui aiment les écrans super
amoled et les amateurs de photos
maintenant le motorola moto x 4 un écran
5,2 pouces full hd lcd double carrière
un 12 mégapixels autofocus avec une
ouverture de 2.0 et 8 mégapixels à des
couvertures en 2.2 avec un grand angle à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de saïfi en
16 mégapixels avec une ouverture de
l'objectif en 2.0 côté vidéo vous filmer
en 4k à 30 images par seconde il a un
processeur snapdragon 630 octas core
cadencé à 2,2 ghz 3 giga de ram et 64 gb
de stockage qu'on peut monter jusqu'à 2
tera il un design assez propre à
motorola la folie qui fait tout le temps
de métal qui est vraiment très sympa qui
a un côté vraiment très précieux
vraiment premium le logo motorola qui
est très sympa tard hier on veut
reconnaître quelques dizaines qui est
vraiment bien pensé au niveau de la
caméra arrière c'est un smartphone qui
est très sympa très agréable de prise en
main côté batterie vous avez une
batterie ion 3000 milliampères heures
c'est un produit qui tourne sous android
7 points 1 point en ouganda il a du
bluetooth 5.0 une prise jack et on
trouve au tarif de 358 points positifs
de ce produit c'est l'autonomie il a une
excellente autonomie points faibles les
photos qui sont assez moyennes de toute
façon il faut de plus mais sur des
appareils à moins de 400 euros à padang
ville à qui ils s'adressent ça c'est un
produit qu'on peut acheter si on cherche
un produit je dirais à s'équilibrer une
bonne batterie côté design il est sympa
avec le dos en verre il a plein de
qualités il brille pas dans un domaine
en particulier mais il est sympa et pour
finir le smartphone français le week au
bio prime alors français oui mais pas
fabriqué en france si un produit qui est
un écran 5,7 pouces avec un ratio 18 9e
avec une résolution de 1440 par 720
pixels à l'arrière vous avez une caméra
5 mégapixels avec le flash qui est ici
et à l'avant une double caméra vous avez
une caméra en 20 mégapixels et en 8
mégapixels flash lui sur les caméras en
8 mégapixels qui vous donne offrir un
cadre classique comme on peut retrouver
sur différents smartphones et maintenant
on va essayer avec le grand angle enfin
mégapixels et on qu'on a effectivement
une vraie différence côté vidéo vous
filmer en full hd il tourne avec un
stage dragon's 430 il a 4 gigas de ram
et 64 giga de stockage côté design c'est
un faux borderless il a un grand écran
un design assez sobre classe 5 une
batterie 3000 meilleure paire eur et
toute chose un wilko unis sur un android
7 pour 1 ou bien il adoube où tous 4.2
une prise jack et on trouve au tarif de
260 euros point positif c'est l'écran
5,7 pouces ont 18 9e point négatif la
résolution de l'écran 1440 par 720
pixels il a un angle de vision qui est
pas génial si vous n'êtes pas vraiment
fasse un peu de côté c'est pas encore ça
alors à qui s'adresse eu la main très
clairement à tous ceux qui cherchent un
smartphone à moins de 300 euros 260
euros pour un produit français ça va
c'est bien il ya rien à dire dans
l'absolu alors on a sept produits sept
produits plus ou moins différents lequel
se démarque en termes d'écrans alors
pour moi très clair sur l'écran c'est le
samsung galaxy à 5 vous avez un écran
super amoled et ça en terme de qualité
par rapport à tous les autres censures
du lcd ces scans meilleur pour moi le
plus mauvais ça serait le iphone et ce 1
4 pouces en 1136 parc 640 comparé au
reste on trouve des écrans full hd ou
alors là carrément avec le super amoled
de samsung pour moi le top c'est le
samsung le plus bas c'est l'iphone et
ses côtés appareils photo aux maîtres
aussi un gros plus au samsung galaxy à 5
tout simplement parce que les photos le
traitement d'image de samsung est
toujours impeccable si maintenant je
voulais filmer en quel cas je vous
conseille le or neuf ou le motorola moto
x 4 on peut aussi filmer en quelques
iphone et ce mais je suis pas sûr que
c'est là qu'on est les meilleurs
résultats côté utilisation du processeur
de la mémoire vive pour moi c'est le aux
normes uhf si vous cherchez de la
puissance c'est le hors d'oeuvre qu'il
vous faut côté design j'irai aussi sur
l'honneur neuf parce que je trouve
qu'ils ont le lait design est plus joli
avec ce ver anodisé avec ses courbes
c'est vraiment élégant alors une fois de
plus c'est aussi le point négatif c'est
les traces de doigts mais il faut dire
que parmi tous les produits qui sont
proposés aujourd'hui pour moi le or neuf
et au dessus après je mettrai le
motorola les motos x4 pas mal aussi dos
en verre plus typé élégant mais qui fait
aussi la faire le reste c'est assez
classique côté batterie pour moi c'est
le honor neuf batteries 3200 milan
terreur qui va effectivement
on pensait la puissance du processeur il
évitait d'avoir un téléphone qui se
déchargent énormément un autre qui est
très très bon au niveau autonomie c'est
le samsung galaxy s 5 qui fait
parfaitement la sphère côté os on est
sûrement android c'est juste regretter
qu'on aime android 6.0 marshmallow sur
le galaxy à 5,1 à ios ou apple gistau a
honoré son sur le sur l'iphone est ce on
adule hutu 5.0 sur le motorola mais
sinon on reste relativement lent des
standards 4.4.2 un extraordinaire des
prises jack 2 partout tous les
smartphones ont la particularité c'est
compliqué de faire impression choix mais
pour moi pour mon utilisation celui qui
sort vraiment du lot c'est le samsung
galaxy à 5 déjà parce que vous avez un
écran super amoled et parce que samsung
est vraiment bien en termes de qualité
de photos etc en plus l'autonomie est
vraiment génial ce que je regrette mais
tant sur sa part ace et l'android 6 po 0
marshmallow donc après une fois de plus
sur différents produits moins 400 euros
sont vraiment avoir un bon appareil qui
fait vraiment le job on peut peut-être
assurant que sur des tigers n'ont pour
le prix je vous le recommande pour moi
c'est meilleur dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est ce que ces produits
pourraient vous intéresser qu est ce que
vous êtes en recherche d'un produit à
moins de 400 euros et puis est ce que
vous y retrouver dans tout ce que je
vous ai dit lequel vous plairait est ce
que vous envisagez de changer surtout
dites moi fait téléphone vous avez
aujourd'hui j'ai hâte de lire vos
commentaires merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo vous invite à mener cette jolie
pousse à vous abonner pastour a toujours
toujours et toujours plus de contenu
pour parler d'eux technologie des guides
des conseils des astuces et bientôt du
voyage du voyage pour light et comme
d'hab restez connectés et moi je vous
dis à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]